the concept of linking is foundational
to good rankings and understanding the
internet
at large it starts with the premise that
good content
will be cited by others recommending it
to other people
how we cite and recommend information
online is by linking to it
we link to information that we find
valuable
based on that the search engines assess
content
by how websites link to one another
so we are going to cover the definition
and purpose of links
and the different functions that links
serve
we'll also look at how links mirror
human judgment
we'll look at how search engines
evaluate links by mirroring
human judgment and how that affects
what's called block level analysis
and how where the location of different
links and how they are used
will greatly affect their relevance
we're going to look at how visitors from
different linked
sources will behave differently based on
where they came from
and also how you can measure the
effectiveness of links
and finally we're going to look at both
good and bad
linking practices now links serve a
number of purposes
from a functional standpoint they
usually
are our primary means of navigation
online we click on links
we go to different pages and from those
pages we find links to other pages
links are also a method of citing
other content when we quote somebody
when we use information that we have
found somewhere else
we cite that information to give credit
to the original author
typically online we do that with a link
so that if someone wants to see the
original source document
it's available to them that also helps
to provide
credibility to you credibility to the
author of the original source
as well as assigning importance to the
knowledge
that came from that original source and
the authority
of the original source links
also provide us with a clear structure
of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can be
so let's break down the functional part
of a link
this is important if you're going to be
developing anchor text
and linking to understand the structure
the ahref equals is the start of the
link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference
of where the document is contained
that's the href reference is what it is
short for
what comes next within the quotes is the
location
of the document now this can be a full
url
or you may just be linking to a document
that's on the main root level of your
server
this is the full location where you can
access the document
and so you're putting the name of the
document the extension
so that it will be linked
the next part is what i have in
caps you'll notice off to the left i
have something in all blue text and
underlined
which most people will recognize as a
link you see
when it is in between the document
location
and the closing of the link tag the text
you have in there is what's called
anchor text you see instead of
publishing
the document location and the full url
of the document
we can put the link within text
and create anchor text so all someone
has to do is click on the link
and the document loads for them this
anchor text
is vitally important to understanding
how we can add additional relevance
to linking content then
we see the closure of the link tag
this is what makes the internet the
internet
is millions of pages connected together
by links
so when we look at the functional side
of links
and we look at this example here as you
can see the title of this article
is not the url address of the article
it's a title and the title is the link
that is the anchor text
of the link and so from a search engine
standpoint
search engines look to see what words
are being used
in the link and how relevant those words
are to the document that is being linked
it also looks to see where is the link
is it in the editorial information in
the article
is it part of the navigation is it in a
sidebar
or is it an ad and then also search
engines are looking to see
if this is a text link or an image link
how long has that link been there what
type of link is it
does it go somewhere within your website
does it go to another website or is it a
reciprocal link which i will explain
more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context to the page
with the link directs you to
utilize links a little differently you
see from a human standpoint
whenever we refer information to another
person
when we provide reference material to
another person
or even if someone asks us for a
recommendation
we provide this information you see
offline
we mirror the same behavior as we do
online when we link
people ask us for information and we
provide it
we just mirror that online by making a
link
offline we recommend we refer
we provide information to each other in
much the same way
the way i want you to think about it
from a human standpoint
is that if you asked another person for
advice or directions
or a referral are there certain people
that you would trust
more than others i'm sure the answer to
that is yes
and maybe you have some people in mind
that you are thinking about
you see we run across the same issue
with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites
that are much more trustworthy than
others
just like if you were to ask someone for
information
i'm sure you would ask the right person
for the information
you would ask the most knowledgeable
trustworthy person you knew
who had authority in that subject area
the search engines are trying to do the
same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites
they're trying to determine who is the
most trustworthy
and relevant based on the
recommendations
referrals and citations of other
websites
to other websites who are the websites
that are trusted that are authorities
the search engines are trying to do from
a technical algorithmic standpoint
what we do naturally from a human
standpoint
now from the human side as i had said
before we need to think of links as
information that we receive from other
people word of mouth advice
information directions recommendations
this is where we need to think about
links not from the standpoint
of building false relevance for a search
engine
but being a helpful resource for our
readers
how can we help them how can we provide
information and how can we be a credible
source of information how can we develop
our authority within the industry
and so that people who have questions
about this content
will see our websites as authoritative
and credible resources the best way to
develop
links as you'll see is good content
when people like what they read when
they like what they see
when they are willing to recommend it to
others it's because you have created
something of value
and they'll link to you when they feel
that you are credible
and that you are authoritative with this
information
only then will they share it with other
people because
you have earned that right for them to
share it with others
by providing content that is informative
educational entertaining and you've
provided that service
only then will people then want to
recommend it to others
by linking to it
now links serve a number of benefits
when i look at
some of the incoming links to my site
one of the things i notice is that if i
get a link in certain places
that can drive a lot of brand exposure
i can have thousands of people coming to
the site
looking to see an article and that
provides a lot of exposure to a lot of
people
however also getting a link from a
certain website
especially if it's a high relevant
authoritative website
i can see my rankings increase because
of that
but then also a good link is going to
drive
people that will convert and drive sales
or leads those who become customers
so those are the three aspects of a good
link
a good link will drive traffic to your
site a good link
will assist your rankings and a good
link
will bring in business if you can get a
link to do all three of those at the
same time that's what i call the golden
link
because it has all three benefits
usually however you're going to find
that different links will provide
different types of benefits one of these
three or maybe two out of these three
one of the things i'm usually very
focused on
is the link that drives sales or
generates leads
that's getting links in the right place
that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see it
why it benefits me financially if i can
get a link
in the right place
so from here let's break down the
different types of links
we have navigational links we see these
in our navigation our primary navigation
maybe the footer of our web pages where
we have
links to typical information such as
about us or contact us
we also have sidebar links this might be
related information
or offers or calls to action
and then also i would break it down into
outbound or inbound type of navigation
outbound are links going to other
websites
inbound links are links that come from
other websites
and that also i might send to other
pages on my own site
now i've used the term editorial an
editorial link
is a link that is found within the
content of the website
and by that i mean through an article
so if i am writing an article and i link
to someone else and
cite them or reference them
that is what's called an editorial link
it means that it's part of the content a
great example of this is that
the navigation on your web pages is not
part of the
content it serves a function as
navigation
but it doesn't have anything to do with
supporting information
with citing an authority so information
and links that you put within the
content
and presented content of your site are
considered editorial
now there's also call to action links
where you're bringing someone to a
landing page
or a registration page or a sale page
then also we have social links now these
can provide a variety of means but
typically a social link will go to a
profile
maybe it's a username that takes you
somewhere else
or a comment or maybe just an image or
something that goes to a social site or
that you have placed on your own site as
well
either way it's all contained within
that social network
even though the links are going on and
off your site they tend to be controlled
in that social environment
now i've used the term reciprocal link
now
this is something very specific
a reciprocal link is one where you would
go to somebody else
and you would make a trade such as if
you link to me
i'll link to you and maybe you put those
links on the home page or maybe you
create a page
just for that link you see sometimes
it just doesn't make sense and so the
search engines will see that
you've linked to each other but if
there's no contextual relevance
if there's no contextual relevance most
likely
you won't get any benefit because you've
agreed to link to each other
for the primary purpose of boosting
rankings
now this is not to say that two websites
can't link to each
other because there is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this module
also then we have advertising links
these can be ads
banners anything on the page that is an
advertising
link that if you were to click on it you
would go to that
advertisers page those links are
typically through
an ad server and they take place in
entirely different ecosystem
but they are links and we need to
know what kind of links are advertising
and which kind of links
are functional to our websites
now when i broke down the different
types of links so we have our navigation
links
we have links in our sidebar and in our
footer what block level analysis
does is that the search engines look at
the code
of the page they break down the page
because it's very easy to figure out
which part of the code has to do with
your navigation which part of the code
has to do with your sidebar and your
footer
and which part of the code is calling
ads from an ad server
with this leaves is the editorial
content your article
and the ability of search engines then
to break down
your page into these different elements
the reason why they do it is that
the links contained in the editorial
space
are considered to be more relevant
in terms of linking to other websites
than any of the other types of links
on your web page search engines don't
consider all parts of the page
to be equally relevant which is okay
because neither do humans we look at the
navigation
as utilization pure utility
because it's just helping me navigate
among the different pages of your
website
i'm not expecting to learn anything i'm
using it as a
functional means of navigating your site
now your sidebar might have some calls
to action it might have links to other
pages
but it's not an article it's what you've
developed and so it might be a little
more important than your navigation
but it's not as important as what you
may have written
within content your footer navigation is
basically the same
you control that it's the same on every
page and so what the search engines are
looking for
are the unique content the unique
article or information that you've
published and if there is a link
within the editorial content that is
highly relevant
because it has to do with content it has
to do with information that you are
sharing and so the links there are going
to be more highly relevant
and are going to be more important for
the search engines to see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation
to learn something it's functional the
same thing with the footer
and as humans we're reading the content
that you have in your article
if you link to another source well
you've provided us with utility
but it's contextual utility because
you're citing where you found
information
or you're citing an additional source or
you are linking to an example
and it enables me as a human to see that
understand it and if i need that
additional information
i can click on it and go to it so i'm
going to look at the information on the
page
in that article very differently that
i'm going to look at the
headings the navigation the sidebars or
the footer
because the article is what is informing
me
and so the links in the article i'm
going to look at very differently
and hold them in a higher level of
relevance
now over time search engines have had to
refine the algorithm
about links you see in the early days of
search engine algorithms
they used to simply count the amount of
links then if one site had more links
than another
that made it more credible however once
people started to figure that out
people started accumulating links by
really any means necessary
and they would just looking for the
sheer volume of links
because they knew if they got the most
amount of links it would affect their
rankings
and so over the years the search engines
have had to change and adjust and
add more relevance to their algorithm
refine it in order to look at different
aspects of links
in order to properly determine relevance
so over time it wasn't just having a
link it was then also looking at
how many people cite this site as an
authority
so looking at the source of the link and
the types of pages
then also looking at the text of the
link and matching it with the text of
the page
does it match is it contextual and then
looking at the type of link
doing the block level analysis and then
also the
context the relevancy of your site
compared to the linking site compared to
the link
and the information that's being shared
there
also some of the ways that they can look
at it at the age of the link
how long has that link been there humans
do the same thing
when we look to see how long someone has
been in business we're looking at
credibility
and then of course there are many many
other ongoing refinements that are going
into
the search engines evaluations of links
sometimes the age of the link
isn't as relevant especially when you're
looking for something that has happened
very recently
an old link could mean that it's old
news or that something has changed
since then so search engines are in a
constant
battle to ensure that people are not
gaming the system by falsely creating
relevance
through linking the link relevancy
and the algorithm is all about trying to
determine
who is the most relevant and credible
within this area and that is the focus
of most search engine algorithm
refinements over the past few years
and it will be into the future now this
is where i'm going to start bringing in
some screenshots
from a link management program
as a search engine optimizer a link
management program
is probably going to be one of your best
friends as you move along in this
industry
in this example this program link decks
that i'm using
will track the incoming links to my
website
and it'll also provide a breakdown as to
what type of website those links are
coming from
so i can see how many links i have from
blogs how many links i have from news
sites how many links from wikis how many
links from directories
forums social media public relations
sites
articles or additional resources
then i can also add my competitors
and i can compare where i stand in terms
of the amount of links from each source
and where my competitors stand in this
way
i can be sure that we all have a similar
link profile
you see if my linking profile looks
vastly different than all my competitors
the search engines are going to see that
as well and know that something might be
different with me
good or bad and that's going to raise a
red flag
so i want to look at the linking profile
because every industry and
almost every business is linking profile
is going to be a little different
but especially among industries we see
that linking profiles that is
the amount of links from different
sources is going to be slightly
different
for every different type of industry or
business
so this helps me understand where my
links are coming from
which is vitally important because from
a business standpoint
one thing that i've tracked consistently
in analytics
is that people will act differently and
also i can predict which
source is going to send me the best
customers
you see just because someone comes from
a link doesn't mean they're going to buy
or become a customer or really become a
lead
many times they're going to come look at
your information and leave
and based on how they come to your site
whether it's through a blog
a directory a forum or a new site
has a lot to do with how they view your
website
and it's all about the context you see
this is what i've learned over the years
is that people will behave differently
based on how they find the website what
i found is that
people from blogs news sites and
articles
they tend to stay longer do more and
have a higher chance of conversion
of becoming a customer or a lead
the main reason is because blogs and
articles
they have a lot of context it's an
article someone has taken the time to
write some information out
and then link to my site which means
there is a highly contextual reason for
someone to click that link
also what it means is that there's a lot
less competition for that link
when my link is in that article
compare that with social news or any
type of social site
you see when you're on a social site and
you're looking at your social stream of
information
there's a lot of different people
competing for your attention
a lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area
it's usually from multiple subject areas
and so
the context is very low because there's
a lot of different types of information
and the competition for your attention
is very high
because of that people from social sites
or applications
tend to visit more often but they only
tend to view
one page and leave immediately because
they're
looking to see what was interesting and
then they move on to the next subject
that's the difference between how people
react
based on where they come from and so
when i'm measuring links
i'm looking to see which links do i have
what's the source and then how do those
sources
behave differently from one another and
why
you see if i find that i'm getting links
from sources
that people are staying longer doing
more and converting at a higher rate
then i'm going to continue to focus on
building links in those areas
because it directly affects how i
monetize my website
so here's a strategy in building links
one of the things i'm looking at is the
source of links
like i said if i can find a link source
that's providing visitors that will stay
look at my content engage with the
content and eventually convert
and convert at a higher rate than other
sources
of content or visitors then i'm going to
focus
on that source and so i'm going to look
at some high authority websites
whether they're industry publications
news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high authority
blogs articles news sites
that's what i'm looking to do i want to
find the most authoritative website
and sometimes it happens naturally
if people that work at those websites or
manage those sites if they find you and
they like your content
they'll link to it and that way you can
get more credibility more relevancy
certain people certain organizations
certain websites have more authority and
influence than others it goes back to
the question that i asked you early in
this module
that how do you know if someone is more
authoritative than somebody else
we also have mid-authority websites
which you can get some links on
and low authority websites which are
very easy to get links
but here's what i've learned when it
comes to link building
one link from one high quality website
can be worth hundreds or thousands of
mid to low
quality links ultimately
it's about quality not quantity
one of the things that i will do
utilizing my link
software is look at the context of the
link
i want to see how relevant this is so as
i said if i want to find a high
relevant website what i'm looking for
in terms of this is i want to see the
influence
of the domain as well as the relevance
of the domain
those are two factors that we're going
to look at
when we're evaluating the quality of a
domain
now as i'm looking at this report here
what influence means
is that it is a high quality website
that within the linking algorithm these
sites
have a lot of authority however
they may not be relevant so for example
they may have a lot of sites attributing
authority to them but they may not be
relevant to my industry which is why we
have the next
column of keyword relevance you see when
i'm evaluating my links
i'm looking for the sources that are
both
influential and relevant
that means that i've got a link from a
site
that fits the two standards of high
authority
it's authoritative and relevant now it's
good to have links from authoritative
sites that
might not be relevant it's still
authoritative
however to get the full benefit i want
it to be
influential and relevant
but not to say that i'm not looking for
links from these other sources
this is just a means of measuring what
you have as well as comparing it
to your competitors and other websites
now here's some best practices when i'm
optimizing anchor text
i want to maintain contextual relevance
so i want to use text in the text link
and i want to explain to people what
they're linking to
what they're going to find when they
click on that link
if i use an image as a link i'm going to
use an
alt attribute because if that image
doesn't show up
that attribute is necessary
to let people know where to go but also
i do get a little tiny bit of benefit
by using that alt attribute within the
image link
i also want to look at the relevance of
the source page that i'm linking to
and make sure contextually the link the
link text
and the content of the page is
contextually relevant to the destination
page
i also want to be sure that i don't over
use the keywords
that i don't make multiple links to the
same destination
that i don't use the same anchor text
over and over
i can be downgraded or even penalized by
the search engine algorithm
if that is found on my pages
so as an example instead of using click
here
for a how-to article i might use the
exact phrase of how to fix whatever it
is
and use that as the link to the page
that has the content
that's a simple way of looking at anchor
text am i directing someone
to additional information if i am
then how can i present it to them so
they know exactly what they're going to
find
and link it appropriately
i look at it as developing the next step
for your readers where do you want them
to go what do you want them to do
what resources do you have available to
them how can you structure them
so that they're easily understood and
you're explaining
the final destination
like i said if you over use anchor text
you can be downgraded or penalized by
the search engines
so what i will tell you to do is number
one avoid
overstuffing anchor content that means
needlessly repeating keywords in the
anchor text
don't do that avoid being redundant
meaning don't have four or five or
six links with the same anchor text
going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know
that you're going overboard don't just
randomly place links throughout your
text
just to get the link ask yourself
are you really helping the reader find
the information they need
and do it once and then also
avoid extremely overly promotional words
within the linked text such as best
expert
cheap number one those types of things
so a couple examples we can save for
travel advice
click here but i would say
here is my travel advice and
link travel advice rewrite it be
creative
it were easy everyone would be doing it
but this is where you can write things
in a better way
to get the attention of the reader and
position it as a resource
also utilizing your url as the link
air as the anchor text as well for the
link
in order to get that click as i've got
it here
i would not recommend that you use that
i would recommend that you avoid that
also the third line but check out the
best website for iphones and iphone
accessories
utilizing overly promotional words is
one of those ways that you can easily
get caught by the search engines
now for future considerations when it
comes to links
realize that the majority of algorithm
changes are link
based evaluation refinements because
people are constantly attempting to fool
the search engines
and develop a false link profile
you should work to create high quality
links
with high quality content i wouldn't
chase
after poor or low quality links
now as i've mentioned before there are a
number of tools
available for you to manage and measure
your backlinks
tools such as link decks moz raven
advanced link manager
majestic seo and then also you can use
your google analytics as well
however google analytics only shows you
the visitors that have come from links
and what they've done
the basic functions of link management
software and there are many
other types other than what are listed
here but
the first thing that it does is just
provide a catalog
of incoming links from other domains to
your site
and your competitor sites they offer
tools for comparison to see
which domains are linking to you what
type of link it is and
on which pages those links are listed
they'll also report newly acquired links
in the past
30 60 90 days or something similar to
that
the purpose of link management software
is to help you assess
high quality domains versus low quality
domains
in terms of importance and relevance
like i said the first job of a link
management tool
is to collect all of your backlinks you
add your domain
and the tools will usually spider the
domain they'll go out into search
engines and go out into many other
formats
in order to find and retrace who is
linking to you
what page that link is contained
sometimes what text
is on that page and what text is being
used in the link
they will catalog all of your incoming
links organize them
format them and report back to you most
of these link programs
provide additional filters and
management tools so that you can get
more
insights about who is linking to you how
they are linking to you
and the type of site personally
i use link decks in order to monitor and
report on my back linking so the first
report here that i'm showing out of link
text
is that i see the total amount of
incoming links to my domain
this says i have over two thousand links
and those two thousand links
are on about one thousand
domains on average it looks like i have
about two links
from every domain that is linking to me
so this is
one way that you start to look at your
links number one
the total amount of domains that are
linking to you
and then the total amount of links
available
this way you can isolate domains that
are linking to you consistently
and also find those that may not be the
best domains
or that are sending a lot of links that
are just not relevant
the next thing i do in analyzing my
links
is to look at the type of link meaning
the type of site that it's coming from
this
report breaks down the amount of links
coming from blogs
news sites directories forums social
sites
articles or resources now it doesn't
usually get
all of those links but it does get
enough
to give you an idea of how well you're
doing any channel
one of the things that i do like about
this report is it also has a timeline
so i can look and see when new links
have been acquired
and maybe when some links have been
just disappeared that's called churn and
it's normal
it's normal because many times a link is
published on social media
and it kind of just goes away or it's
not tracked anymore by your link
management software
it can't find it anymore and so linking
is always dynamic you are always gaining
new links
and losing old links there's going to be
a normal amount of churn
the next report shows me all of the
domains that are linking to me
it also shows me in the next column how
many of those domains are also linking
to at least one competitor
and it will list as many competitors of
i have listed in here
if they list to multiple competitors it
will let me know the influence
of that site or the authority that site
is seen because of the amount of
websites and credibility that authority
has for that domain it also let me know
the keyword relevance
how relevant that website is overall
contextually to my domain and the
content that i have
it will also let me know how many pages
on that domain
have links to my website so i can also
go through and i can filter this
list by the type of site i can filter by
those domains that are using
anchor text to see how much anchor text
is being used
and what type of anchor text there are
many different ways that you can filter
through all of the domains that are
linking to you
in order to get an idea of what's
happening on your domain
what are competitors doing and also the
relevance
of those links to your site
now when i say that i can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one i showed
earlier
where i look at my own standing in the
different types of sources
of links such as blogs directories
forums and so on
i can also when i add my competitors
look to see
how they are performing in those
different areas as well
and so i can compare my link profile
to my competitors different industries
are going to have different
backlink profiles they might be more
heavily weighted towards blogs
or they might be more heavily weighted
towards forums or social sites
in this way i can look to see if my
competitors are actively link building
and how they're going about it i can see
where maybe they are excelling in one
area
that the rest of the competitors are not
so i can compare different strategies
i can also compare different timelines
to see if i am
acquiring links at a faster rate than my
competitors
this is very important if you are a
newer business or a newer website trying
to compete
now specifically what i can do is look
at
an individual domain in this case this
domain
has three pages linking to me and that
domain
also links to two of my competitors i
can look at the specific
pages and what i'm looking at here are
snippets
this should be familiar to you because
what it's showing is the url
of the page that's linking to my page it
shows me
the page title of that page
and then in this report it lets me know
if there are any keywords being used in
the link
in the anchor text as well as the number
of links
from that page now what this tells me
is that this is most likely a directory
something that is listing all the
different places that where you can buy
products
because it's most likely linking to
the domain name seeing that there are no
keywords being used in anchor text
and also that there are 16 outbound
links from that page
that means that it must be a list of
some sort
and they are linking not only to me but
most likely
to competitors as well so i can track my
links at the domain level
and at the page level i can look to see
which pages might have more influence or
relevance
to my content i can also see the link
url
the page title if any keywords are being
used in the anchor text
and also within the context of how many
additional links are leaving from that
page
if there are a high amount of outgoing
links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable
since there are so many links the less
links there are coming out from that
page
the more it will benefit my site because
i'm getting more
benefit from less links
now also what i'm going to do is compare
the link reports to my analytics
i'm going to go to my analytics because
linking
software does not show traffic it
doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link
it only shows who's linking to you but
it does not show visitor activity
analytics will show you visitor activity
to see
which domains are most effective in
sending
visitors to your site you go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business analytics
show me visitors and business it shows
me
which domains are sending me visitors
and which of those visitors are becoming
customers
so what i can do is go to google
analytics
look at all the domains that are
referring
traffic to my site i can also click on
the domain
and see the destination page that they
are linking to
i can see how many visitors are coming
either monthly or annually
how often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users
how long they stay how many pages they
view
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits
this is a great way to get a 360 degree
view
of your linking because not only do you
want links
that will help you rank better you also
want links
that will send business and customers to
you as well
building links can take many forms
ideally
it is through networks relationships and
marketing
that other websites and users learn
about you
like you and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and
untrustworthy advice to be found about
building links to your website
in this section i'll present the best
practices
as accepted by the omcp standard
the objectives for this module that
you'll be able to develop
a link building strategy that you'll
understand
the value of different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link
opportunities the first step in building
links
is to evaluate what you have
now there are many tools available that
you can utilize to do this for you
there are automated tools that you can
get that will
catalog all of the incoming links to
your website
some of them are link decks moz
raven or advanced link manager there are
many that can do that you may also want
to utilize
your analytics as well in order to find
websites that link to you the first step
is evaluating where you are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings
and you can do a lot of on-page
optimization
and see some results however
a lot of google's algorithm takes into
account
links from other high quality websites
now when you evaluate what you have in
this example
i'm showing you a screenshot from link
decks
link decks catalogs the incoming links
to my
website and it groups them into
different areas
the first way it groups them is by high
value
or high influence domains
those are websites that link to me that
have a lot of
influence not necessarily in my industry
but high influence based on the amount
of people
that link to them as an authority
on many different subjects the next way
that it groups that is based on
relevance
now this is when it looks at
the match of my content versus
the content of the other website in the
first example we can see the national
library of medicine
it is a high influence website because
it is a government website with a lot of
information
that is cited frequently because of the
amount of
other websites linking to that site it
has a
high amount of influence now based on
the website that i
am measuring there is a lot of
keyword relevance meaning that that
national library of medicine
site with the government has a lot of
content that's very similar to my site
a lot of the same keywords are being
used
so not only is this website of high
influence
it also has a lot of relevance and
that's key
when evaluating my backlinks
i want to look at which websites are
also
referring traffic so while i may have a
link
from the national library of medicine i
want to look at my analytics
and look to see is it also providing
visitors are visitors following that
link
to my site and i also want to look at
the quality of traffic
that it produces do these visitors
stay longer than average do they convert
more than average i want to look at the
quality of traffic
based on the source next i want to look
at the incoming links from those other
websites
number one i want to make sure that the
incoming link
from the other site is both accurate and
relevant
meaning the text that is used in the
link
is it accurate to the content that will
appear on the page
when the visitor clicks that link is the
content relevant
this is especially relevant if i have
updated my website
changed the content or moved things
around
i want to be sure that that incoming
link sends visitors
to the appropriate page and the
appropriate
information i also want to ensure that
that link is worded correctly
that it uses the right words that is
sending visitors and
setting expectations of the content that
they will see
i may need to contact the website
manager owner
and maybe ask for a better link text
or a more accurate page destination
now this requires some interaction with
the
owner or manager of another website and
you always want to be respectful
of their time and not demanding that
they make any changes
in some cases the organization may be so
big
you may never find the right person in
order to
optimize the text or the destination of
that link
you always want to look for accuracy in
cases where
your company or website name is utilized
in the link
but also if there is any contact
information
such as address phone number a
description of your business
and any content make sure it's accurate
and it all points to the right place
another way to look for links is to
simply go to a search engine
and start doing searches search for your
company
your business your company name
and look for websites that may mention
you
but do not have a live link to your
website
many times your company will be
mentioned or cited
but there will not be a live link you
can only find these through doing
searches
and seeing which websites mention you
without linking to you
now this could be an opportunity to get
an easy link
especially if you can find some contact
information
and finding the right person that could
add
a link to your company information
again you'll need to be polite ask for
their help
and it will help it if you can develop
the link
along with the link text and send that
over
giving them just a quick and easy edit
to be able to add the information so
make it as
easy as possible as an example
i've provided a sample request format
again you want to be polite you want to
be inviting
and respectful of their time and
their management sometimes like i said
you may find the right person that can
help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be
to make this happen this just requires
your patience
and again being polite
and not expecting the company to do
what you are asking many times this is
just a formality
and sometimes companies will act on it
so be sure to approach this with the
right expectations
the next thing i want to look at are
business listings
these are the easy ways to establish
links
and ensure that links are
where they should be and also
opportunities
look for business directories especially
if your company
has a local presence you can utilize
chamber of commerce lists association
lists
or local listings if they are on
websites
see if they offer links that can go to
your website
rather than just the list of businesses
that are in the area
even on a larger level you can look for
associations
directories or listings where you can
add your business
or double check if your business is
there
and always ensure that your business
name
address phone number and url are correct
complete and consistent with other
listings
the next level will require some active
marketing
and that's where you search for
opportunities you can go out and look
for other
resource lists within your industry or
directories
of businesses within your industry and
you can
get a link many times through membership
or submitting your business as a
resource
however you may want to step up your
marketing
you can do that by interviewing your
clients
seeing if they might be willing to
provide a testimonial
and a link to your website you may also
want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your
industry get involved with those
communities
fill out a profile and get involved by
contributing information by sharing
information you'll find
that people like getting information
and they'll respond by linking to your
site
another option is to utilize the tool
that you had for
indexing your links from the first step
you can also add your competitors
and you can look at their backlinks you
can look and see which
websites and which domains are linking
to your competitors
but you always need to go and see why
what are those other sites
linking to and what is the nature of
that link
sometimes it may exclude you from being
able to
approach competitors backlinks
and ask them for links however
if they're being linked to by companies
that are
simply stating here are vendors in this
space
and they are linking your competitors
and you're not there
then it might make a lot of sense for
you to approach and ask if you can be
listed as well
however be sure that the links to your
competitors
are not from a consumer or customer
relationship in that case
it might be out of line for you to ask
for a link
make sure if you approach anyone who's
linking to a competitor
and asking for a link to your site make
sure the context is right
and then it makes sense for them and
that's the ultimate judge of value
does it benefit somebody else to link to
your site
we all know that it will benefit you but
when you present your link request you
need to offer value
and a benefit for others to link to you
so be sure that you present it in a way
that is beneficial
and good for those people that will be
adding the link
they're the ones that have to take the
work to do it and they're also the ones
that are adding
a recommendation for you and your
business
so as always you need to be considerate
and patient
now the best way to build links
is by creating something that people
like
and sharing it you see the best way to
build links
is by creating value through content
or information or entertainment
you see when people like things they
link to it
if they find a study or a white paper or
research that you performed
they link to it if you post a
infographic
that explains something and it's
attractive
people link to it you see that's what's
most amazing
about linking i find that when we
put most of our effort into creating
content that people like
that's what builds the most valuable
and the most relevant links and so what
type of content well you can create
infographics videos top 10 lists
or articles articles with advice or
analysis of market data or even research
that type of content
people love it and so when you publish
it out
you utilize social media to extend the
reach
and the visibility of that type of
content and when
someone likes it they'll link to it and
recommend it to others
now people also like depending upon your
industry or your business
they also like some personality maybe
some humor
people always like expert information
they like the cute this is why pictures
of cats tend to be
liked and linked to more than almost
anything else
and also the unexpected if you can
inject any of that
into your content that just makes it
more valuable
more personable and again more shareable
by other people and every time someone
shares it
it builds a link to your site
you see the best linking is when people
like something
when you create something that people
like and share you might be surprised
at the many opportunities there are
to get links based on your content i've
seen
many many blogs based on cooking fashion
arts sports music and
when people specialize within a specific
topic
they always find an audience and so
anything they publish
builds links even on certain social
media sites such as pinterest
people upload pictures on articles
and infographics especially about
landscaping flowers
food cars you name it there is a special
interest
for anything and you can develop links
from those social sites
to your site and it can generate traffic
even with a blog developing articles
that talk about upcoming events new
music sports
whatever it is when you create content
that people like
it takes the longest amount of time to
build content for building links
when you develop your own content that's
the biggest
investment you'll make in time and
research
and writing and presentation however
the result is that when you develop that
content
you will receive the best and highest
quality
links and the most valuable
links are going to be to that content
as i mentioned before one high quality
link can be worth
more than hundreds or thousands of low
quality links
so my best advice is to create content
that people like
that they link to and that will be high
value links that you'll generate to your
site
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here